okay guys and we are starting a new
quest with psychobabble and as man
Donald Trump this one is the one to get
strong the supermutant that is your
companion and you have to get tourney
tower which is right here okay this is
Simon City journey tower okay it's right
directly see this whole thing right here
between here and diamond city anyway the
quest is called a thing as curtain show
but you'd listen to the radio real quick
there we go ok gotta turn this off and
we gotta kill this [ __ ] right here ooh
bon je vais en de huh oh you there's I
see it coming that way don't even know
their suit me in dogs okay uh he didn't
like that but oh he likes that one
though he likes that one again okay jump
ball he's a boy psycho with his Mandy
Trump you know what I'm saying
[ __ ] oh good get good good
okay come on come on get him Kim good
get all my time come on just one more
time for daddy come on ah oh that is
orgasmic oh it's so hot oh hi I'm
strangely turned all by that family is a
bobble head around here so I'm she gonna
keep looking real quick okay Greg and
babblings I don't send a [ __ ] bomb
and yeah yeah okay I would take the
[ __ ] elevator [ __ ] that [ __ ] where's
my coworker and a [ __ ] companion I
don't know where she is
okay oh there chef I heard someone oh
yeah I shouldn't mere I love to close oh
oh he didn't like that he's like ah why
Jesus good good okay take a lot of shots
here that's right now you're not dead
yet oh [ __ ]
come on boys kill this [ __ ] good good
good saddle him that much help up what's
up oh she just child over there that's
fine what da [ __ ] that was like the
dirtiest catch I've ever seen God suck
my dick nothing makes me harder than
someone in lower class sucking my dick
need to see what these guys got I look
at okay
where are they I hear them I hear them
camps Oh Strong's name of the companion
you got to find the cage at he's into
that Jesus I'm just like strangely
turned on I don't understand it and I
don't even want to try and explain it
okay not really sure what's going on
here you know
she's like in shock she said what the
[ __ ] to do
okay that's fine i guess everyone has
their interests okay okay let's check
out this boy over here you know I'm
saying [ __ ] what a shitty gun
this guy got he's like a broken rifle
suck my dick [ __ ] come on God God God
God get good yeah this is nice a sec
that a piece of [ __ ] rifle I like that i
usually like that but not today these
are those like a safe word I say
oh [ __ ] that I heard like a [ __ ] ooh
back leg what the [ __ ] down there okay
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] Dex come on baby give
me that weak spot baby oh yeah like that
you got a headache now you got a
headache for daddy I wish there's a mod
that like makes all the super mutants
call you daddy you're gonna be so hot
okay okay okay I gotta get God God God
God God God gut gut gut [ __ ] is down
there
let's go up bag by us go up
type Rihanna kiss me right now
yeah listen listen Piper you really kiss
me just say like I don't like play my
games okay Anna kissing lips I kiss you
how about haul yeah uh-huh so it tells
me I'm gonna come here you think got
every year oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] dickwads
were they shooting from Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
dick bricks I'm so bad
come on come on Oh what the [ __ ] come on
stop him oh [ __ ] don't even hit him
right in the [ __ ] face he stops okay
then I have like no chance of getting
them at no scope [ __ ] let's go where
daddy
tough luck is over here what is that a
twister oh [ __ ] so I'm just looking for
that bauble at the same time all right
oh thank you I [ __ ] it up there Jesus
you know this is just like genocide a
sickly
yeah yeah oh there but me yeah yo man yo
man yo man got our trade for euro she is
so loud they know one of my level okay
whoo there's so much good [ __ ] here
should take that microphone pais [ __ ]
ton of money ooh okay I can kind I can't
Oh what the [ __ ] Wow maybe take better
to not use [ __ ] vats
[ __ ] a
how do I get out of here [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy gud gud gud
boo fest is not like that oh don't i
have like that super weapon yes come on
get him once let's get him once
Oh
where is he
i'll have like one shot left where is he
gonna find you if I miss I am [ __ ] up
come on where are you
[ __ ]
got him
okay [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is where the
[ __ ] is the girl she needs to carry my
[ __ ] [ __ ] strugglin I got the case of
the shits come on just lie out there she
has come on dude ha she got
anyways what you would slope because
then I could just [ __ ] give strong
the minigun
come on o our rescue you are the first
to actually make it to the cage I think
the super mutants killed us out of here
my brother what Duffy hun cantil hon I'm
gonna put the gun here see what I have
there's got to be a key around here um
move I'm kind of over oh I have too many
guns what the [ __ ]
oh there's the bobblehead right there oh
no it's not just kidding just kidding oh
there it is selkie there it is there it
is baby
how strong he knows the best way down
off of this curse and tower go Julie Rex
go fast humans hey strong oh [ __ ] i want
to give him finish it oh there's the
pilot yes oh what the [ __ ] ooh [ __ ] a
strong
come on come on skyline this guy lying
let's go strong let's go everyone aboard
I care she makes it awesome
civilized his savage was by GG to
strongly believes it is a secret to
human power so wants us to hidden find
it hmm okay Stan I lift our spirits by
voting from the barge good night good
night parting is such a smart make us
lose the good we thought might win by
fearing to attempt they say do never
live all the Devils are here let me
embrace these sour adversity for wise
men say it is the wife this is [ __ ]
insane something
yeah Cal strong gut gut gut had any
money no [ __ ] is this different one yeah
[ __ ] are all here good good good I
glad we read it
eros there oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's so many of them out
hmm hey pepper hey done okay let's go
let's go
hello I can't [ __ ] ow if you're in
the way okay I'm walking I really want
to give this armor to this guy some
forgive me here we get man [ __ ] Egon
okay guess he's just [ __ ] leaving
yeah I just jumped down Oh talk to our X
Goodman okay we're good as long as you
don't like how a [ __ ] aneurysm right
now we get say in an average let's
player would I just walk down these
things out may not may Rex many thanks
without timely rescue yeah come you know
welcome as gracious as you are brave
years well in any of it time I grateful
I'd like you to have this now if you'll
excuse me I think it's time I left
returning to WR VR and resuming my
career in radio
mmm I got a lot of XP okay guys um so
that is the end of a curtain call and
now we have yes um strong it's also
rules so thank you for watching guys I
hope y'all enjoyed that the hope you
learned something today I hope you feel
me as a friend okay not much prettier
that's a Spanish